don't make me [ __ ] stab you on a
monday morning
i gotta be in county jail my lifetime
what
satisfaction when we're done what the
[ __ ] people wake up [ __ ]
monday april 14th
the day the devil was buried at sea and
he got [ __ ] in the ass that's how
lucky you are qriketly kick it nobody
said to lower [ __ ] huh up
jumping jacks get up wiggle for me
ladies it's been too long come on wiggle
funk with joey
he's the spare ribs all weekend oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] living like a doctor
it's the church of what's happening now
you bad [ __ ] wash your helmet
sling some dick powder your balls gonna
be a hot day today oh [ __ ] what's the
story lin
what the [ __ ] what's been all week lower
that [ __ ] what's up i mean if i was in
vegas for the week vegas for the weekend
you have a nice time you jump up and
down what concert you go see lana del
rey how did you get [ __ ] tangled into
this night man my girl likes it was the
concert itself the
her herself is a very good sinner
but it was uh what is she saying
kind of like ballad sort of stuff i
don't know i mean you feel like taking a
fork and stabbing yourself in the eye
second
herself are fine
i haven't been to and like
i haven't seen people like that ever
so it was at the cosmopolitan show is it
seven at 5 30 we get there just because
she wanted to be close up front she like
she liked that she used to get there
like 10 hours early
for shows and
that was never my that was never my
thing i'm not i'm not really into
concerts um so we get there and it's
like kind of like we're like the third
line so they have a ballroom filled you
know how they have like lines and movie
theaters with the ropes they did that
with big tables so we sit there for an
hour and a half
and when they oh please open the door
these like 100 pound 20 year old girls
start pushing the tables over and it's
like it's like the black friday scenes
and they start rushing for the doors and
the cops have to slam the door shut and
we're all it's like it's like black
friday
so after like 20 minutes of these
crazy people pushing and shoving we get
in
and
we're like in the middle of the crowd
now in front of the stage
and people are elbowing you and pushing
you and i don't like people i don't know
touching me i get i get claustrophobic
so about 20 minutes into that before
right when the opening guy starts about
an hour in because the door opened at
seven opening guy didn't even start till
eight so around eight around eight
o'clock i was like i gotta go sit down
somewhere i told her to use the bathroom
and i just went and sat a little bit
outside of the concert room
i sat there for like 20 minutes
composed myself
got a couple of waters for her and me
and she when i left she's like you're
not gonna be able to get back in and
i've been a con i i go to the jumping up
and down israeli guys and yeah it's busy
but you can get back in you can walk
around like a human being when i try to
walk back in with the waters you would
have thought i was going to
murder these girls families
they were elbowing me they weren't
letting me and i was like listen i'm not
trying to stand here i just want to get
to my where my girlfriend is with these
waters
and i'll leave you alone and they were
like they weren't they were letting out
me and i had to like push some girls out
of the way and after like five minutes i
just couldn't get to her
it was it just wasn't happening
so i texted her i said i'm in the back
if you want to come if you want to stay
there i understand so she came out we
stood there
when she when lana del rey came out it
condensed even further she paula told me
that when she used to go to concerts she
would come home at the end of the day
bruised up
i don't understand that at all
these these girls
were throwing punches just to like see
this concert and i was like what the
[ __ ] you gotta you gotta you gotta get
you gotta talk to these people you gotta
sit this girl down no no no i can't go
to these [ __ ] i won't go we
i don't know how you fall for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] lana del rey give her 10 bucks
for the [ __ ] cd you're gonna go to
vegas to see what i don't write get it
together but it was just it was getting
beat up by girls what the [ __ ] is going
on in your world liz what do you do all
week do you hang out with [ __ ] little
[ __ ] or you hang out with flavor what
are you going to go to these things well
[ __ ] it what is your what is what lana
del rey what is wrong with you in vegas
next time give the girl 50 bucks and
send her on her own you're going to go
to like a [ __ ] mama to get beat up by
girls what is this [ __ ] well next time
i'm not going but it's just the [ __ ] is
matter with you
we talk all weekend who thinks people
are going to act like that
we talk all [ __ ] week what are you
even going to these [ __ ] disasters
for
who gives a [ __ ] you give us fifty
dollars go see lana del rey i do you
know one of her [ __ ] songs you know
not one of them why would you [ __ ] go
sit there like a [ __ ] momo uh oh this
song is great yeah it touches my who
gives a [ __ ] lana del rey next time you
give her a yard stick and you send the
solo
she'll [ __ ] go then she ain't going
to go no she'll go with your friend next
time then you let it go with a friend
you're going to put up with that [ __ ]
lana del rey in las vegas i could see
led zeppelin killing yourself for bad
company or somebody i think you know who
knows who's coming to the forum and uh
englewood it's uh fleetwood mac that's
great go see that one too you've been
down for that forum but wait did you get
stabbed by that [ __ ] apollo liverpool
good tell her to go to that one solo two
little [ __ ] forum i thought i thought
[ __ ] lona del rey fans would be
little girls and then it would be like a
nice peaceful concert like i said do you
know any of her songs no no
why would you go to that [ __ ] thing
no you don't you give them a yardstick
if you said i'm gonna go see these
[ __ ] jews she don't know who the [ __ ]
they are with me
listen if if it was some other [ __ ]
obscure band okay you know what i'm
saying like some guy's [ __ ] you're not
gonna take her with you
what's the matter with you lana del rey
you give her a yard stick you give a 50
coupon to either that's what you do with
girls you can't just say you can't say
go alone you go with your girlfriends
you don't put yourself in that
predicament well next time i won't
because no what the [ __ ] and four hours
away for this [ __ ] a hotel room no but
we stayed for the we had a good time
otherwise we had a good time
you're eating spare ribs those are good
what was the name of the chinese place
noodles and noodles and where'd you stay
at uh
trump and how was it good it was was it
packed las vegas no not thursday friday
and saturday friday [ __ ] yeah like i
said and then friday's even slower
saturday is the big night in vegas yeah
friday fridays were a little bit was a
little bit busy really was busy a little
bit saturday was definitely busier and
what night was the show uh friday okay
so then what'd you do saturday just
apply we gamble we do what i want to do
and i i i ended up winning so okay
that's [ __ ] what no it's one they
have a game called blackjack switch
where you have to play two hands but you
can switch cards around
that's how you win that was fun
i don't know [ __ ] it it was just it was
something you loved the gamble i love
you oh i love game like i love you
you're such a dirty little degenerate
jew i love it it's in your blood i don't
know how to [ __ ] you like your face gets
red oh yeah i love it i love it that i
would never get that from you like i oh
i love it and she got pissed off of me
because i was up okay
i was up 295 when i left
i wanted to get that five extra bucks
and i ended up losing 80 because i
wanted to get that hundred dollars but i
still i still ended up like three or
four hundred for the weekend so i was
happy
but uh
that's what that's what you have to do
you have to go with someone who doesn't
like gambling because they'll pull you
forward
yeah yeah a little self-control so you
were yeah you wanted to win the three
even and you got the [ __ ] who got the
burger yeah but no i didn't lose
everything look because she got pissed
off she's like we're going now before
you lose [ __ ] everything [ __ ]
gamble too
only two because we we took one of your
flights we took the 650 flight out of
vegas so we was already back las vegas
the line was already filled in the
mornings it was just about dude we got
it we got there like we got that like 5
30 and if we waited until six it would
have been mad
um
but it was it was it was a fun weekend
it was uh
you know when you travel with a person
that's when you can find out if you're
actually gonna be okay and and the
concert we didn't fight about the
concert
uh we didn't fight about the gambling
really it was a lot of fun we went to uh
bobby flay if you ever go if you're ever
in
if you have a little bit of money to
spend and you're in the caesars palace
mesa grill is one of my it's [ __ ]
delicious
i had a rib eye it was [ __ ]
it was uh chipotle something it was like
a little bit spicy it was oh tremendous
yeah it was [ __ ] amazing
how was grand rapids before you [ __ ]
yell at me about
it all right so london del rey was it
would have been fine but these like now
i can see why you're writing that book
for how to be a woman for for for mercy
because i i was i was blown up i was
blown when they started pushing the
tables over and he would boom boom boom
and i looked back at me
and all that that hour and a half
waiting in line was wasted because
everyone just started running and the
cops were like what the [ __ ] how many
people were at this place
it had to be a 500 600 at
least if not a thousand mexican people
a few mostly white girls from l.a like
just uh yeah probably
no it's [ __ ] craziness i've always
had problems with concerts in smaller
venues yeah granted big venues they have
control of it's a bigger venue yeah but
at smaller venues it's always kind of
[ __ ] up you never know and they're fun
if they're really fun they're fun yeah
but if it goes sour in the beginning
people pushing and [ __ ] it goes better
i've never went to a concert with people
pushing like once i got to that [ __ ]
i can't i can't i'm like you i'm like
yeah i don't like being touched and
people being sweat on me i would have my
mind you could sit down like why don't
they have seats in these things i don't
know i don't like standing up either for
[ __ ] two hours like to sit down and
then you get up and then
you [ __ ] gets up and you gotta stab
him in the neck yeah it's a [ __ ]
night grand rapids let me tell you
i've always been a fan of michigan
always since day one i don't know why
i had a friend jim wheeler who was crazy
from uh detroit a white dude that i
loved with all my heart he he was there
for me when i got locked up he taught me
how to sell cars
and he used to have that shirt that said
detroit the murder capital
of the world really always tell me about
detroit that's why when i had the
opportunity
to get paid the first time and my friend
todd jordan asked me what do you want to
do comedy i said joe you know detroit
i've always wanted to go to detroit and
once i went to detroit i started
exploring michigan you know i would go
to grand then or i'd go to [ __ ] this
one place to do it one night this is 13
14 15 years ago
before anything you know i was just
traveling around michigan
doing stand-up for john yoda at these
one-nighters that were [ __ ] out
but i really got to enjoy michigan like
there was something about the people the
girls
you know people were very open-minded
about weed and this and that oh they've
always been open-minded about it yeah
yeah yeah no no no it's always been a
great [ __ ] city you know the decline
of detroit is one thing that's nothing
that they can't control but i'm talking
about michigan as a whole
it's a beautiful [ __ ] state to drive
through the seasons
you know you go up up up all the way up
towards canada mackinac island it's it's
i mean traverse city it really is nice
so
you know
listen for me to not go anywhere in the
tr in michigan is is painful for me i
hope that this opens the door now that i
could go to more places like flint and
lansing and [ __ ] uh what is that like
is it hard for comedian to get into i
guess the word is market is it like hard
to get into the state if you haven't
been there
you know every market is different every
market is has different uh people that
you have to go through okay and you know
the market that market has a ton of
comedians so it's very hard for for him
to bring people in
you know he has no reason to bring
people in he has so many great comics in
the midwest
that don't travel that just stay in the
midwest okay so when i got in i had to
cancel last year because not a brooklyn
nine-nine something else i had to cancel
for so i didn't wanna cancel
grand rap you know when i got into grand
rapids i had been there this is what i
did and i started thinking about it in
98 i went back to detroit with a girl i
used to date and i just called john yoda
one day out of the blue and i go look
i'm a comic from la i'm a regular at the
store this is what i've done at the time
i'd done baseball and maybe a pilot for
cbs
i go i'm not calling you the headline
i'm calling you for 25 minutes a night
he goes i have an opening week do it
doesn't pay much
and i did it and i did okay and i got
hired to do gay pride a lot in the grand
rapids and i went back and they gave me
a fifteen hundred bucks in a line of
blow and it was [ __ ] great and i
never went back to michigan again but i
had a great time and i used to go no and
towards the end i would always be in
either saginaw
travis city let me get one of those
walters lead dragon travel
set saginaw travis city i would go to
those places bay city to do comedy stuff
like that so
i had no idea what to expect at dr grins
this weekend
and what i expected was [ __ ]
pandemonium
when i tell you [ __ ] pandemonium i
mean pandemonium i mean that place was
packed
all five [ __ ] shows
crazy [ __ ] people uh you know [ __ ]
jew t-shirts everywhere [ __ ] i love
it you know it was just it was just
really good to go there like i was
overwhelmed if you asked some of the
people that came thursday night and
maybe friday and they thought my head
was somewhere else i was overwhelmed
because i knew people were going to come
but i didn't know that many people were
going to come
and it was just really cool you know
people gave me edibles they gave me
edibles for you
some beautiful girl made me a plaque
that said no momos
my main man gave me a t-shirt for mercy
a michigan state spartan t-shirt for
mercy
it was just great the [ __ ] i had some
salmon at that restaurant
with ricotta and [ __ ] mushrooms and
red peppers i ate the salmon every night
i ate the salmon every night the hotel
was great i mean it was just uh
listen man comedy for me now it's really
wild how at shows people always pull me
over and they embarrass me because
that's what you do when you say those
things to me that
the podcast is helping you by me
admitting different [ __ ] things you
know the drugs the the prison all this
[ __ ] let me tell you something this
podcast is helping me
as much as it helps a lot of people
because it keeps me in check
i have to be at my best around you
[ __ ] people i swear to god i have to
be at my best now i just can't be a
regular comic i got to go the extra mile
for these guys you know it's really hard
to describe like when i used to get on
stage before i didn't know what i was
going to do
now even if it's an old joke i'd rather
you people laugh
than me take a gamble with you anymore
like that's to the point i'm and i and i
throw new things in there i'm constantly
writing
but it's so weird how much i care for
you guys you know how much i try to do
the best that i can i try to leave it
all out there for you so as much as you
guys are [ __ ] helping me out or i'm
helping you out in the way with the
podcast and talking about mistakes and
being wrong or whatever the [ __ ] we talk
about here
it is what it is i'm sorry about last
week also with the [ __ ] ladies
yelling
you know it was great radio as my man
timmy holloway said but we don't deserve
this [ __ ] we we hide we got this office
they know what the [ __ ] we're doing
so we're gonna and what happened last
monday to be honest with you was that i
went away from my normal frame of mind
i'm trying to do different things with
the podcast i don't want to be that guy
that does the same [ __ ] every [ __ ]
week so i try to bring guests in here i
try to have different type of people
call in
last week i made the podcast later which
i didn't like at all monday's podcasts
are always at 6am i want to get up with
you [ __ ] i want to see what
you're feeling i want to be there with
you from the [ __ ] weekend you know we
all feel like [ __ ] on monday morning who
gives a [ __ ] there's no second place
medals on monday yeah it really is you
gotta get the [ __ ] up and do it and
that's why i do this [ __ ] monday
mornings at 6 00 a.m and from now on
mondays will be monday morning at 6 00
a.m we're gonna move to an office where
we could smoke reefer if we wanted we
could jump up and [ __ ] down i could
scratch my balls i'm gonna get a
microphone we're gonna turn this into a
morning
show for you [ __ ] because you
guys are putting all the effort in for
us we're gonna do the same thing and i
want to touch on something really
important because i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
lee like everybody else i say stupid
[ __ ] every [ __ ] day i was gonna say
from time to time you know every [ __ ]
day i say stupid [ __ ] and if you don't
say stupid [ __ ] every [ __ ] day
you're not gonna get something good from
time to time about three years ago i was
doing a podcast with joe
and uh
we were talking about twitter and
facebook and how i didn't want to be a
part of it you know i'm like i don't
want to be a part of that [ __ ] and they
were talking to me and telling me listen
if you're [ __ ] in jail
will one of these idiots from facebook
or twitter [ __ ] bail you out
what a [ __ ] mistake i said by saying
those words what a [ __ ] mistake you
know
now we fast forward three years later
and i gotta tell you something guys
i don't believe in [ __ ] you gotta
[ __ ] i'm from missouri [ __ ]
you gotta show me i you know i'm one of
those [ __ ] you want to talk
about bigfoot bring them to my [ __ ]
office and then i'll talk to you you
want to talk about martians bring them
over here and then we'll [ __ ] talk
i'm the type of guy that if i talk to
you about something it's because i've
experienced it or i haven't experienced
it or whatever but i'm not going to hear
the [ __ ] stories just to give
something light
something happened last week in the
facebook twitter community as far as the
church community one of our friends
uh lorne
uh you know isn't that his last name
doesn't matter he's been with the church
since day one you know he's been with uh
he was me and felicia
this guy's a good guy on facebook you
know post music i say little things to
him
he hits me back last uh
you know i don't know what night i don't
even know if i have the freedom to
devour this but last week he lost his
son he lost a 16 or 15 year old boy and
i can't imagine the pain
and he had sent me videos to look at
thursday or something and off wednesday
and i
wrote them back and i was going to look
at the videos on the plane because that
guys i can't look at all the [ __ ] you
send me when you send it to me
a lot of times i have to look at [ __ ]
when i have down time that's why i
answer the emails on sunday because i
have two hours i can't answer them to
you right away because it would [ __ ] up
my whole day
so i try to position everything in
chunks in my life
so i didn't look at the video so i was
gonna fly
before i could when i went to open the
message for the video that he had linked
it on
he wrote something that joe it's okay it
really doesn't matter now
last night i found my 15 year old son
dead or whatever his son you know and
at first i thought it was a joke
you know i thought it was a joke i mean
we all joke around and we [ __ ] around
but then i looked at it
and i clicked onto his page and i knew
that something was different about him
you know something he was getting
different messages
and i gotta tell you something i got
busy in my own world and i put it away
you know i put it away and like i think
i had to do a show or something and then
i came back that night
and i really started looking and i
started reading the postings and
guys it was like i knew this man
because i broke into tears over the loss
of his child i broke into tears while i
was on facebook i felt so bad i felt so
[ __ ] bad i understood his pain you
know i really felt this kid's pain
and i think that uh i ate my words when
i said those words that day on the rogan
podcast we are a family here
we know
i gotta tell you something guys i i know
you guys gonna think i'm crazy we're
connected here in some way on this
[ __ ] show or on this internet because
i felt what this poor man was feeling
through his child
and what we're doing online right now
with whatever even if it's a thousand of
us i don't really give a [ __ ]
but just the people that are in we're in
man and we're on to something we're onto
something online this is these are
stupid [ __ ] wires man these are
stupid [ __ ] wires and i could feel
his pain through those [ __ ] wires on
a [ __ ] computer
what does that tell you man we're doing
something here it's not the church don't
tell me it's the church or it's this
[ __ ] jew gambling jew
it's you guys it's us
you know we're on to something and uh
the church family that's it we become a
family no more fame i don't want to hear
this [ __ ] no more man
i don't want to hear this [ __ ] no more
i'm going to make new patches and new
shirts this is the church family
because this is what we are you you guys
have shown me something that i've never
had before in all my [ __ ] life lauren
uh
we all our hearts go out here for your
child if there's something we can do for
you you know please let me know on
facebook
and we'll all get together we'll put a
gofundme whatever the [ __ ] you need you
haven't asked for a dollar you haven't
asked for anything you've been a man
but we're just here to tell you that
we're here for you man thank you and
we're sorry it's uh i just want to let
you know because sometimes when you're
in the middle of this you don't see your
friends
so i i get messages sometimes for shout
outs to dudes on the thing i just i i
say thank you but it's not my place to
do it
uh his friend evan messaged me yes
because i i i was going to tell you but
you found out before so he was he didn't
and he didn't ask me to mention him but
he was the one who told me about it i
don't know if he told you about it yeah
he did too it was i already know but i
wasn't gonna give him one this is not
about a [ __ ] shout out for long
yeah because his son passed i just wanna
know the lesson i learned from lauren
this weekend uh
you know little [ __ ] musically don't
just [ __ ] sit there [ __ ] i
learned the big message for more so i
thank you and i'm sorry it was took a
death to make us realize
fuckingly
you [ __ ] suckers where's these edibles
at
that's it where's the gummy bears at
[ __ ] huh you thought i wasn't gonna
open this huh you thought i forgot
[ __ ]
huh it's monday morning [ __ ] i don't
think you ever forget about an edible i
don't think where's yours it's right
here well eat that [ __ ] thing it's
over that's it
you always complain you're not eating
breakfast i didn't eat breakfast i'm
opening it now and i'm going to i'm
opening it i never got no credit
oh cool
green or red and green
got to be cool i'm not even
give me a [ __ ] break too then five
milligrams a piece it's 20 milligrams
the whole thing
which ain't doing right there oh this is
good
yeah
tremendous [ __ ] monday april
14th wake up you [ __ ]
it's gonna be beautiful out there today
anyway
what the [ __ ] me stop drinking water in
one second
it's a beautiful day to be stopped
drinking water
no it was um
yeah not that uh
was i say the uh
uh some uh yesterday you know in 1984
when i was home
uh
i went back to new york for some reason
because i'm an [ __ ] i want to be a
girl or something
and i went home and something happened
in april that yeah on palm sunday that i
forgot all about there was a massacre in
new york city
they massacred a family
a mother
and nine kids maybe a man or something
but they were all kids they were all
kids from
five i don't know what the ages were it
was one of the most horrible things i've
ever seen in the newspaper
they showed the funeral
okay on easter sunday they showed uh the
inside of the daily news was a picture
of a funeral parlor it was just caskets
it was like a small war yeah
and at the time they had blamed on the
colombians that the family had owned
colombia and some money or some [ __ ]
like that
but you know life went on i forgot all
about it yesterday morning i get up in
grand rapids and i'm looking at the
computer the more i'm drinking coffee
and there's an article about the 30th
anniversary of this massacre how
in all the blood and all the kids and
all the parents that were there they
found the baby that was 13 months old
that was walking around the blood
and they picked the cop put that baby up
picked the baby up took it to the
station she had to give her up
there's an emergency family that night
and then she she followed that child
all along to you know to check down the
child a [ __ ] great story i never knew
this you know and it just shows you that
i was very lucky and this girl was very
lucky you know and this cop kept
touching base with her tuppence base and
then when her grandmother died the cop
adopted him oh
and now the girl's 31 years old and this
cop and her husband adopted her and what
happened to her life she all the changes
she went through how she wanted to find
out who her mother was her mother was 20
when she got killed you know
but in the pictures they said that uh
the mother died with a spoon in her hand
and like baby food or some [ __ ] you know
so she always wanted to investigate who
was she gonna feed you know it was that
little baby you know it was 13 months
old [ __ ]
if you could find it's in the new york
times yesterday 30-year anniversary of
the palm sunday mask it's [ __ ]
touching you know i mean
who the [ __ ] would have known there
would have been a silver lining to 10
people dying you know 10 people dying
there's no silver lining but it really
it uh it goes to show you that there
always is a silver lining man you always
uh you think so
because i mean i
so this is this is the question i had
because they've been it's been a year
since the boston one
and they keep playing videos about it
and i'm like dude i mean i guess there
has to be right you you overcome through
through pain but for stuff like that
like sometimes i get negative about it
like i'm thinking like why are they
trying to like why like why do they need
to write a newspaper article about it
like well it's the year uh-huh the year
and then number two they're doing the
show have you seen the show
it's very interesting it's on discovery
how they caught the kids and the
detective getting interviewed i saw it a
couple weeks ago and i think now they're
making a series of it on discovery or
not geo one of those okay
and what they show was from the
beginning what happened the bomb went
off how they took they knew they were
working against the clock how they they
took the cameras and they looked at
people who didn't react to the explosion
and they saw that after he dropped he
went down he didn't react to the
explosion so they narrowed down him it's
very interesting
listen man
right now a year later you're not going
to hear a silver lining story or maybe
you are i don't know i don't know you
know maybe
a guy picked a woman up and you know she
got a hand blown off he took it to the
hospital ended up falling in love and
having children you know we don't know
we don't know if there's a silver lining
to this but i'll tell you what look at
when my mother died you know i got to
find out the gift of friendship you know
the people who took me in and were great
to me uh when i went to prison i got to
find out about the gift of [ __ ]
comedy
you know when i kidnapped ken bella that
day that that morning i got to find out
what i wanted to do with my life what i
could do and what i didn't want to do
with my life
you know there's always something late
you know today if you go home right now
and so god forbid something happens and
you call me and go joe i gotta go back
to boston
i'll call you when i come back and a
year from now you call me and you go joe
i didn't have the strength or whatever
this is what i learned out of this bad
position i was in there's always a
silver lining you're not gonna see it at
that moment you're not going to see it
when you're sitting there at the wake
you're not going to see it when you're
sitting at the hospital you're not going
to see it when you're laying in the
hospital
but you have to believe
what i believe man you have nothing
nothing nothing i i i had nothing
but i always knew that if i could make
it one more [ __ ] day if i go to sleep
tomorrow man tomorrow i might get the
[ __ ] job of my dreams tomorrow
i might hit the lottery tomorrow i might
find a woman it's so much belief you
know people
base this [ __ ] on everything it's just
believing in your heart it's hard to do
that sometimes too like especially
day to day like like you're saying 30
years later
i can't imagine what that girl when she
was like you know exactly what she was
going for i know exactly when she was
eight i know exactly what she was going
through and they didn't want to tell her
oh they didn't tell that to you no i
forget you have to read the article they
told her that uh
they told us something else then she
found that and then she investigated
because you know as a natural you want
to know what your mother died of and
your dad and yeah of course what
happened so uh what's the matter you're
choking up over there we haven't even
eaten the whole thing i'm already
feeling it but it's all right i'm good
you
nothing's wrong no no no no but it's i
think it's interesting because it's uh
it's always so what's the i don't know
what the term is but it's uh
when you're going through something it
seems like it's uh it seems like nothing
good and it seems like it's day to day
but even looking back a year ago or six
months you do see you do see movement
through it
but it's uh i guess now it's hard to not
be cynical
about about a lot of things so i guess
it's
it's good to find the the good things
that happen you have to
you have to because if you sit there and
look at the negative you'll die in
[ __ ] sorrow you'll die you'll [ __ ]
die it just it just makes no sense to
you you know it's it's
i'm telling you i could sit here the
book i'm writing right now about the
biography
is about the bad things that happened to
me or the bad things that i created that
happened to me that i was part of
creating i'm not going to sit here bad
things happen to me no
and what the lesson was i learned from
them okay
you know i i i went to blows with my
uncle who was on the podcast
that uncle 30 [ __ ] years ago
you know in 1984 i went to blows with
him on [ __ ]
vermont avenue the uncle that was
sitting in that [ __ ] chair
four weeks ago
you know we cursed at each other we were
gonna [ __ ] kill each other i mean
being in prison and prank calling them
and telling them in spanish i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you
i was [ __ ] living at him
but
that day he gave me a message you know
he told me that the world didn't know me
[ __ ]
i didn't want to hear it at that age
finally when i was in the cell four
years later
i understood what the [ __ ] he was
talking about okay i understood what the
[ __ ] he was talking about you know some
of you guys watch or listen to this show
and you think that [ __ ] joey's an
[ __ ] or whatever or
you are young enough you have parents
you have moms and dads you have a father
who's went to college who's educated and
you don't give a [ __ ] what comes out of
his words you'll listen to a guy like me
before you listen to your educated dad
who came from a decent family and
whatever it's really weird that the
people that we pay attention to in our
lives you know i'm saying yeah our
parents are our heroes but sometimes
they're [ __ ] fuddy-duddies you know
why won't you let me go to the concert
in vegas you know my friends are going
they're not that they're telling you
you're going to go and you get an elbow
with chicks
you don't want to go there you're going
to waste your time give the chick 50
bucks stay at home snort some coke and
get some chick to come over and lick
your ass so you get the same [ __ ]
result
but uh
it's just amazing how people
you know i don't even know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about this [ __ ] edible
already yeah no no i was smoking vapers
this morning
uh
i knew you were because you were looking
at that and the camera's pointed at me
and you're like looking at the camera
that's not even there i don't even
[ __ ] know what i'm looking at i don't
even know what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
cameras are in this room because things
turned around and satellites and [ __ ]
and
i got [ __ ] clint eastwood looking at
me i got a lot of people bothering me
but it's just amazing the things that
we'll pay attention to and the people
that will pay attention to the people we
listen to yeah that's the point of this
[ __ ] story so and it's hard because a
lot of times you don't want to listen to
the people no that's what the [ __ ]
happens with your parents damn who the
[ __ ] wants you don't know nothing you
don't know nothing and all of a sudden
you see yourself
in that position listen man if i were to
listen to 40 percent of the advice i was
given
from the age of 20 and 30 i wouldn't be
on a podcast sitting across from a
chubby jew at six in the [ __ ] morning
you understand me i'd be at home right
now getting my [ __ ] feet manicured by
three asian chicks each foot three asian
chicks each foot like one holding it one
polishing the other one going
just blowing the dust off my toenails
you understand me if i would have
listened but i didn't listen i had all
the [ __ ] answers
you know i had all the answers so now
i'm a comic that carries his [ __ ]
luggage every weekend you follow me i
could have had my own boat my own
[ __ ] island by now you've been living
like marlon brando but no
we all think we're [ __ ] smarter than
our predecessors and we're really
[ __ ] not but if we take a little bit
of advice that they have to offer us
you know three or four people we could
probably [ __ ] make it happen now did
you realize
when did you realize like with your
uncle when he said the world doesn't owe
you anything when did you realize that
he said that and that was an important
one four years later when i was sitting
the [ __ ] jail cell like towards the
end of my sentence when i realized when
i got my reports and i
and i understood my fate i understood
where he was coming from i understood
where
juan my stepfather was coming from when
he said don't do this don't do that stay
on top of that
you don't
learn nothing till you're in that
position yeah you know to you're in the
hospital so you got stitches in your
[ __ ] head
you got stitches in your mouth or you
got handcuffs on you never listened to
advice why would you you got all the
[ __ ] answers
no you're not the kiss of death
no that would never be you everybody
else is [ __ ] wrong and and it sucks
when you realize they were right
right at the beginning when you're like
[ __ ]
and it always happens with my mom for me
because she always tells me things like
mom what are you talking about that's
not right and then a few years later i'm
like god damn it and i have to call her
what what happened when you [ __ ] uh um
my mom did some mr paul said something
to me recently and it it went back to
what my mom had always told me and i was
like i have to call my mom and tell her
oh my god damn it and it but you know it
always helps but
and uh do you hear someone like that
where like they tell you something
you're like god damn it they were right
you know
it's it's not the advice that people
tell us it's the advice that we give
ourselves sometimes because sometimes we
have the answers number one we always
have the answers oh yeah we just don't
want to [ __ ] hear them sometimes
so sometimes think like last week when i
went down with felipe in here i knew it
i knew it i [ __ ] knew i i came back
to me this is what i get
for not sticking to my [ __ ] plan
this is what you get for not sticking to
what you've been doing all your [ __ ]
all the way why would i do a monday
lunchtime podcast
why would i do something like that i've
been doing it at six in the morning
getting myself [ __ ] fired up ready to
stab a [ __ ] every morning and no
i decide to do a lunchtime podcast to
come in here like some [ __ ] david
letterman
sidekick you know talking some stupid
[ __ ] questions at lunchtime no i like
coming in here early and yelling and
screaming and getting my day [ __ ]
going and getting the spirits momentum
and the juices going because that's what
[ __ ] mondays are about it's not about
getting up at 10.
i can [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's about getting
up at five and going you know what what
happened last week ain't gonna
[ __ ] happen this week yeah this
is gonna be a way better [ __ ] week
i'm gonna sharpen my dick i'm gonna
scrub my balls i'm gonna put the other
and i'm gonna go out there and stab
[ __ ] 15 times in the neck and
that's what happens i want you to be
better than the last [ __ ] monday
every monday that's what i strive to be
yeah my goal is every monday to be
better than i was last [ __ ] week
that's why i used to go to wait watches
on sunday so monday i'd be [ __ ] ready
you didn't eat the other [ __ ] gloomy
i'm already feeling this one no but
y'all it's five milligrams one more
let's do one more
one more
one more one more
are you uh disappointed you didn't get
the call for letterman
oh yeah i was sad at home let's do one
more out of respect it's monday it's my
let's do it for your irs one more come
on dude i already ate the whole [ __ ]
bag good i'm glad you did you ate one
two ten milligrams i'm asking you to eat
ten
ten [ __ ] milligrams played half of
them no one one whole one it's five
milligrams of [ __ ] things
the body of christ compels you and you
give me the christmas pack too a red and
a green one that's good it's christmas
every [ __ ] day of your life you want
a purple one no i'll trade you a purple
one for a red one
these have to be 20 milligrams no
they're not eat the [ __ ] seed
the body of christ compels you what the
[ __ ]
we got my man call him up when you're
[ __ ] worried about
it's five milligrams this time eat the
[ __ ] thing [ __ ] that's what
it's all about
you got sugar in there to kick up your
diabetes you know what i'm saying i'm
telling you
you're saying you suck sugar right to a
[ __ ] top who's better than you
who's better than you tell me right now
answer me
who's better than [ __ ] lisa yeah no
one oh god nobody
oh thank you guys i'm for grand rapids i
saw the they made a little vine video
for me so that was oh god they missed
julie
black dog labs these actually taste
pretty good they're good they're [ __ ]
really good man cut it out you think i
would [ __ ] have they're five
milligrams of pizza no no you're never
an [ __ ] but it's just it's just a lot
of [ __ ] animals
what a lot of edibles what you waiting
[ __ ]
tempi
was a lot of edibles trust me people
love seeing you sweating oh of course
they didn't and i i'm just getting
tweets that you were sensational in
tempe i'm getting [ __ ] hit from
people saying lee
was tremendous in tempi he was sweating
his face was red oh god yeah he kept
saying oh my god oh my god oh my god
like somebody was [ __ ] the [ __ ]
cool you know what i'm saying
oh thank god i didn't go to temple this
week because i would have had to drive
through coachella
can i at least get some credit for not
going jumping up and down and going to
coachella
can i
i went to vegas i went to one concert at
least i'm not going to two weekends of
[ __ ]
jumping up and down
i do i deserve a little bit of credit
you get [ __ ] who gods
[ __ ] sucker going to some girl concert
you give her
you should have duped her a yard let her
go to the concert and you could have
gone and played blackjack by yourself
that's what a smart operator i would i
can't leave her i can't wait she's a
[ __ ] woman i know i like that [ __ ]
you're gonna go to some [ __ ] half a
fat conscious and ah
she's playing the piano barefoot
whatever the [ __ ] she does you gotta sit
there make believe you're having a good
time oh this is great this ain't [ __ ]
great would you tell me the truth would
you would much rather be playing
blackjack than someone
i'd always rather be all right now who
the [ __ ] stop lying these people at home
this is what the show's about [ __ ]
honesty you're gonna sit there oh this
is great
you know what i'd like to have call on
it's i don't know if it's a psychologist
or whatever it is
but
as soon as i start gambling even when i
was there was like all right i'm gonna
go back this weekend and i'm gonna go
back and make more money it's it's a
[ __ ] it's it's a weird thing seeing
the degenerates in vegas
well just wait so you see that how's the
gamblers do you get scared tell me the
truth like i get scared when i see
certain the degenerates i get scared but
we were there and we walked in the
bellagio and this guy almost had twenty
thousand chips he must have got one of
those markers and my uh my dick got hard
i was like
he was playing 500 a hand and i looked
at her where the second one was so you
know what twenty thousand looks like in
chips i was it was it was i i don't know
i'm just i don't but it was like it was
stacked
i'm not i'm not here to [ __ ] with you no
no i don't know what twenty thousand
looks like are they like ten thousand i
know there's like thousands it could
have been more five thousand dollars it
could have been more it probably was
more i think it was 100 chips but he had
a stack in front of him like four or
five six
columns up and i was just looking at it
like what the [ __ ] was he playing
blackjack yeah
poker poster what the [ __ ] am i saying
blackjack and he just was oh i was i
just looked at paul and she pulled me
away because there was a 500 minimum
hand table it's like what the [ __ ]
what's the highest minimum you've ever
sat down to play
i've played at the 50 table when i made
a mistake a couple times i want to go i
played 300 a hand just because
what what happens is you try to win
money back and you start playing stupid
that's not how you're going to win the
money
so i did that a couple times and then
that's when i drove back the same night
and i was pissed off i lost 800 bucks um
but [ __ ]
there's some and thank god i don't live
there
because i would be [ __ ] i don't know
how people go to college at unlv
it's [ __ ] there's something in me
that this and my grandfather loved it my
grandfather went to the track every day
and something in me that
that just pulls me towards it do you get
mad while you're losing money at all at
yourself or not while i'm playing but i
start playing stupidly you have a good
time oh i love it and i love it i have a
rule
and it's not racist it's a rule that i
learned from someone else you don't play
with lady asian dealers
for whatever reason they're always mean
and there's one table i was at this
weekend it was just a i like it's a it's
a it's very social i'm not a very social
person
but the deal and i were talking you
always talk to someone sitting there
it's a great [ __ ] time of a drink
it's always it's a lot of fun and
especially when you're winning you're
high-fiving people you're knocking on
the table when you want to get a
blackjack it's a lot of fun you just
play blackjack and you do poker i i have
to learn poker i have to learn okay now
these casinos downtown l.a that are used
to go to pocatello
yeah they don't play blackjack there
they do a little bit but you have to i
don't know i'm asking you no they do i
i've lost money there but they have bad
they have the machines that shuffle for
you and that's bad and then you have
some of them you have to pay a dollar
each hand you want to play what stops
you from going through those things i've
been to a couple
like when we leave here what stops you
from going there's knowing i'm gonna
lose that i've i when i i went to
commerce casino a couple times
and it's just
it's nothing like vegas it's like a big
con it's like a big warehouse of sadness
and it's just uh
i like being i like the big i like the
big buildings and it's happy and the and
and i like dealers more nice at places
like that the dealers yell at you and
it's just uh
i would love to learn poker
but it would also probably be the
downfall of me i i scratch an itch when
i go every six months to vegas if i went
every day i wouldn't come here let me
ask you this i'd sell this computer
just to talk about
dreams and hopes yeah would you consider
learning to be a dealer
uh
maybe but i don't want to be around that
every day okay just i'm just got
questions for you
it would but there's so some of them are
so good we there's a guy on speaking of
friends on facebook and twitter there's
a guy talking laura who's a good guy
who's one of the security guys right and
he told me what he said that some of the
bigger casinos some of the dealers make
a hundred grand a year just because they
have to be they have to be so fast and
so good at it and they have to be able
to count and have to be
sociable and bring people in
it's it it's amazing when you really
think about it all the stuff that goes
into it
but
you you're never going to beat babies
how come i'm not again really a guy like
me
doesn't lose his mind every week because
i have all the makings
of being a gambler my mother was a
degenerate gambler yeah you know i grew
up in that environment
uh i cannot tell you that i don't love
it i cannot tell you that i don't love
sports i'm 50 [ __ ] one years old i
can't sit there and watch three games on
a sunday yeah and when i was 20 i
couldn't sit there and watch three games
on a sunday not because i hated football
but because i felt guilty i need to make
money i need to do something with my
life i'm sitting there watching three
[ __ ] games and then take a shower and
go to a bar to watch the sunday night
game or the monday night game really is
that what my life is all about maybe you
hate
losing money more than you
want to gamble
because for me i hate losing money but
i luckily for me i never got into any
sort of drugs i'm not an alco i don't
drink
so maybe addictions
kind of lead towards other things maybe
maybe the thing you have with drugs was
your addiction and that took you away
from gambling
well it's funny because my whole thing
was
i paid a bookie on thursdays a couple
times
and did i like it no because i would
have to rob
because i don't like when people don't
pay me so i always believe in paying
people so i would not
let myself have to call you and say hey
lee i don't have your [ __ ] money
so i would rob you know and i enjoyed
robin you know i enjoyed that part i'm
not gonna sit here and lie to you people
and say it was a gun to my head
i enjoyed doing the stupid [ __ ] i was
doing in 1819 and this was one that
really affected me at that age when uh
it affected me uh
in 83 when i moved with a friend of mine
called fernie basulto his brother's on
facebook now
fernie was my friend i loved fernie
dearly
uh
one of the pains in my soul today that
the three guys i was closest with
growing up
they're not around in my life anymore i
i don't really have them i don't know
roger uh glenn and ferny are doing their
own thing and
you know part of them doesn't like
talking to me whatever roger does roger
does timmy does who i gave a shout out
to me holloway
and it's so weird that uh
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i was
gonna say i was involved with the
gambling with them you know glenn
my friend glenn was a degenerate also uh
fernie never gambled in his life he came
to me one day he said he wanted to put a
bet in what are you guys always talking
about five times and ten times
he ended up putting a hundred time
parlay in and one holy [ __ ] 100 times
first bet ever but a hundred times paul
and one what happens to a guy i thought
he gets sucked in oh yeah he went right
down to the bookmaker's house and picked
up 1200 bucks we went to a restaurant
called piccalissimo
we ordered the lobster fried diablo this
is how [ __ ] crazy this kid was you
know what a finger bowl is where you
wash your fingers and when the seafood
comes okay he drank the water out of the
football he had never been to a
restaurant that night before in his life
just giving you an example of where his
head was at from [ __ ] that day in
october
to super bowl sunday in 83 which it was
82-83
he didn't stop he gambled every week and
he was up like 50-60 grand you always
win the first time yeah but he always he
was winning the whole season oh wow he
was betting basketball winning and then
came january the super bowl and he ended
up losing the 60 he made
plus 20 000 to his friends
and then for a month he just bet 40 time
parlays three times a night to bet
basketball and if you want to catch up
on sports basketball is not the [ __ ]
way to do it every day yeah it buries
you you know remember the prime
gambling part spots in this country uh
september
to [ __ ] february first once that soup
bowl is over
60 percent of the gambling has done in
this country for sports is done because
you have college football
pro football
college basketball starting up you catch
the beginning of it it's still green in
december so you can make some money you
got pro basketball starts in november
you have so many different sports that
are playing you have
college on thursday nights and saturday
all day saturday you got pro now on
thursdays yeah
sunday morning sunday night monday
[ __ ] night they give you all these
avenues to to [ __ ] gamble you know
and that's what i've always said that
thursdays is like putting the one
[ __ ] uh needle in g the the nail in
jesus
friday is the other nail in his hand
saturday those college games are nailing
your feet
sunday is the thorn in your [ __ ] head
and monday footballs and they stick that
spear in your [ __ ] heart
it's the 12 stations in las vegas you
know what i'm saying they don't [ __ ]
around las vegas that's why
it it scares me because you're a very
nice guy
when you go to las vegas it scares me i
know that you're well i i have some
rules i always go to the atm when i'm
here and i never go to an atm there no
and on top of that they might steal your
[ __ ] number remember always in vegas
at least you got to go into your
personal stuff
the better i got nothing against vegas
it's the people it's what the thing is
made of i have that rule i have uh i
don't carry all my cash with me like
i'll bring a little bit of it to the
casino
because i don't want to get robbed and
i'm breaking like paula when you
whenever you go to the cashier paul
would just walk away and i said don't
walk like i always move to the side i
always i don't walk around counting my
money i'm very careful
um i don't play games i don't understand
like i try i was going to play craps i
just don't understand it so i have rules
like that just
i'm there's nothing there's no better
feeling for me than winning the money
but it's just when you lose
that sadness like when i when i went and
came back the same night after losing
800 bucks well you said that oh
that that drive home is a depressing
drive home and i i didn't even stay the
night in the hotel
i uh
i was staying at the i was i was trying
to make money so i stayed at the quad
and they give you a 25 credit for food
so i lost all my money but as i was
walking back from the hope from the
casino i took all my the loyalty cards
they gave you and i threw them out on
the street i threw them out in like in a
trash can i took the 25 food credit and
i got i think i just went to the to the
only open restaurant and i was like
give me this i just got all the way up
to 25
i went upstairs i hadn't you know
unpacked my bag in the in the room i
went i got my bag and i took the
disgusting pizza i just drove back home
it was
it's uh
it's a it's a terrible thing when you
lose and i think that the little bit of
losing that i've had that's have
happened to me is what's keeping me from
going other casinos because i would love
it there's nothing there's nothing no
who wouldn't love to be living in vegas
going to casinos but you see them every
once in a while especially in the sports
book especially
watching the horses
i i sat next to a guy watching the
horses who was hammered out of his mind
but he was picking every race and he's
picking it right
but it's just really he maybe when he
went maybe when he actually bets he
loses but when he's picking it
beforehand he wins every time i don't
know it's just
and i gotta tell you something and i'll
tell you this
right now man some of the best times
i've had i've been at a horse track oh
yeah i love the track
but i go to the track for 40 hours yeah
and once i lose the 40 hours it's over
and that 40 dollars has to get me an
iced tea a hot dog you know some
entertainment when i'm there for me
there's nothing better than smoking a
number and going to santa anita and
getting some sun yeah yeah from clam
chowder whatever when i was a kid i go
to the meadowlands just to get the clam
shot if i got a bowl of clam chowder
that means i won for me
i [ __ ] won you know so well isn't
everything kind of i mean i don't want
to say it's the same for drugs but maybe
it is maybe maybe if you could let me
ask you if you could have kept your
cocaine habit
to
20 dollars a night friday and saturday
would that have been okay for the rest
of your life just doing it just doing a
little bit just to no because now a
little bit but that's what i'm saying
for gambling if you can just do a little
bit just bring 40 to the track once
every few months
just to have fun and be outside with
your wife that's better than the people
who are going to the atm or
doing the title loans on their cars like
i feel like that's when you start
losing it so i i just don't know maybe
maybe drugs is just always bad well for
me it was this this is this was my
philosophy at the time
i was doing drugs and i was gambling so
my [ __ ] big thing was okay if i'm
gonna give somebody money every thursday
and not get dick yeah not get dick you
hang this guy an envelope but he's like
rough week huh yeah all right see you
next week no i'll see you that's all you
get from your bookmaker if i'm gonna do
that i might as well look get coke try
to get my dick sucked and try to look
out windows all night because that's
what happens you look out window you get
paranoid yeah that's what you want
another one no these are [ __ ] strong
and [ __ ] they ain't [ __ ] strong
[ __ ] they're good they're [ __ ]
they're delicious they did a great job
this was given to me for by [ __ ]
friends
in uh grand rapids
it's called black dog edibles yeah they
gave me uh they gave me a couple a
couple i ate them the first night
some other couple made edibles like made
cookies that were delicious yeah i
brought a bunch of those gummy sermons
speaking with
how good of the time do we have tuesday
night that was fun did you tell these
[ __ ] tuesday night we went to
aries uh this isn't this is not
happening show
and i did that's what we were talking
about uh role models last week and you
know what
if i answered 70 [ __ ] emails last
night yeah 30 of them were about role
models really everybody was confused
everybody said the same thing everybody
was like wow
i had
athlete you know athletes but i realized
it was a great time the uh gumis and
manos came those guys don't [ __ ] around
that ghost [ __ ] they were so
[ __ ] high and they drove down from
[ __ ] wherever they live up north
doing the [ __ ] dabs in the couple he
said he said he bought a piece
specifically because it fits in the cup
holder
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about listen guys let me tell you
something a lot of people watch because
of this california thing with the wheat
a bunch of [ __ ] fakes popped up
thousands of fakes they walk around with
their eyes like this like that jesus and
man
they ain't [ __ ] they don't even smoke
good [ __ ] weed i know half of them
they take two hits of garbage weed
and it's just to impress you [ __ ]
morons shame on you for being impressed
but then you get [ __ ] that come
along
that reefer isn't that [ __ ] nutsac
you understand me like it's who they are
you know i have friends like that like
edwin san juan rifa is in his [ __ ]
nut sack he travels with a pipe that
would kill most [ __ ] people he used
to travel with a quarter pound that
would see he's used to me ralphie
ralphie may those [ __ ] smoke
some dope okay
he knows gets [ __ ] wasted every time
i just found an old mad flavors world
on uh email that you sent me to look at
before you put it up and it was the one
with them in san jose oh yeah it was
just i saw lee 2010 i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
2011.
and i looked at the video and it was one
that you had put together of them and i
don't know if you remember i go look at
these guys and they went in their pocket
and they had a torch oh yeah do you
remember that that was two [ __ ] years
ago they used to show up at the san jose
improv with a [ __ ] torch and banana
bread and cookies and [ __ ] bags of
dope and it's just mind-boggling so they
show up uh thursday tuesday tuesday
night i go late when we drive down it's
[ __ ] hysteric because lee calls me he
did the joshua podcast he goes i'll pick
you up
after that and i told him right there
there's no picking me up you're parking
the car i'm driving you because they're
bringing a special boomi for you oh god
we went over the lower canyon went down
there the storyteller show was great it
was packed
there was tons of people my agent was
there
darren carter was there you know just a
gra
greg from chandra keys office was that
his name i think so brett ernst was
there
i mean we laughed our asses off
and then we went outside and then i told
my wife we'll be home by 11.
we got home like at 1 30 or something
like that it was [ __ ] well you gave
me a [ __ ] head of the gummy and and
you think okay so these guys are go they
make gummies
and they have a couple people out here
you think maybe they have a setup these
guys were walking around with a shopping
bag
that couldn't have been more full of
gummies and they were handing it out
like they were santa claus
just and they were ahead they gave you
like i don't think you could even hold
the amount that they they gave you
and [ __ ]
and then after that they were like so
you want to do a dab after that head
when i cross the street and start doing
dabs right in the [ __ ] street
and i did a dab and i gotta be honest it
shut my [ __ ] lungs down yeah it just
shut them down it was like having asthma
i couldn't [ __ ] breathe
did you see me standing yeah they have a
[ __ ] heart attack i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] have a heart attack
and i was like that's it i can't smoke
this [ __ ] number one and i'll tell you
what i'm going on two months on [ __ ]
thursday
without smoking a joint do you believe
that or doing a bong here
no physical on [ __ ] thursday just
vape isn't that one [ __ ] dab you
believe that lee well vapors dab is kind
of like a vapor i think so isn't it so
do you think you're just gonna keep
going and [ __ ] i'm gonna go until may
17th i'm gonna do it in 90 days because
i'm doing that thing for doug okay and
uh and i'll see then how i feel i mean
i'm having a great time eating edibles
yeah i've got it down to the edibles i'm
not eating edibles that are [ __ ]
really fattening i'm not eating cookies
i'm not eating
big banana bread no more i'm not even
eating the chocolate bars anymore i
haven't seen you with that yet no
nothing this time i've been doing
tiniest you know the cheaper shoes are
35 calories
that's a half a [ __ ] point i mean
weight watchers one point is equal to 60
yeah 60 calories is one point a chiba
chew the decker is 35 [ __ ] points
yeah that don't do nothing that don't do
dick to you all those things that they
make at 35 points you know they make
diabetic stuff and they make [ __ ] with
sugar to kill you that's why when people
go to me we have you know ice cream with
thc and that's great but
i gotta eat that whole gallon ice cream
to get high i don't have that [ __ ]
type of time yeah i just want to pop
some and the other bars those uh
chocolate bars are delicious yeah but
it's a [ __ ] chocolate bar bro i don't
need a [ __ ] chocolate bar i don't i
just don't need it i work hard you know
so
that's it so that's all i've been living
on just vapors
and the edibles how [ __ ] crazy is
that guy oh never
especially after the amount of weed that
you had at my at my last place
how much weed was in that [ __ ]
sadness
you know guys and it's cute and we have
a great time and we giggle but come on
guys
[ __ ] two joints
during the podcast on a joint from 4 30
to 6 before when i leave the house i'd
smoke three pipe fools i wasn't rolling
joints at the house i was smoking pipes
i would fill the pipe three [ __ ]
times jesus i'm not smoking some [ __ ]
susquehanna weed
i'm smoking this [ __ ] that killed
punches pilate
and and [ __ ] you know then i'm
rolling two joints and then i'm going
home after the podcast and smoking
another two joints then i'm smoking
again in the afternoon then who don't i
bump into and then at night it's a
[ __ ] smoker town in that room that
end it had to end somewhere you know
yeah oh [ __ ]
oh and did you
some guys tweeted me that they were
bringing you hummus did they make did
they make you hummus no luke luke said
no no no
no
it would piss me off it gets me angry
i wouldn't bring something around you if
you don't like it don't bring it
no but you like that stuff yeah like
hummus
how much time did you eat any hummus in
vegas coconut oil no no your big shot
[ __ ] accomplished that's during the week
all alone in vegas you're like [ __ ] the
iranians no harmless this is not no i'm
as [ __ ]
is it strong
it feels nice to eat another one too no
leave me alone you only ate that's 10
milligrams the whole bag is 20. i don't
think so the whole [ __ ] bag is 20. it
says it running the thing
look at it the whole thing we're going
to eat another what the [ __ ] total
product cherry can of cube
black dog
19.859 zero
eight
thc
praise one right no for [ __ ] i don't
know i'm already feeling it there's no
way one feeling that they're five get
another one let's go you got a red one
let's eat the green one let's make it
christmas let's go we got one i already
had to run in the green one so let's
have another purple you want a purple
one no thank you and i'll eat the red
one no wait you can have it right now
lee do it for jerusalem
what was the last time he did something
for jerusalem never you've had where's
the [ __ ] jew flag that was supposed
to be on the wall
i
black people everybody's scared of the
flag of israel
you gotta get it together you're
slipping let me give you some shout outs
real quick man main man ryan zick
timmy holloway i love you landon bench
george landry and my man tommy ray water
boxer cleo
my main man lorne rosenker i love you
guys from the bottom of my heart thank
you for listening i want to give a shout
out to my people on it as usual i had to
take two flights to grand rapids and two
flights back i brought the turnaround on
[ __ ] 80s tremendous when i get off
the plane tremendous it's got all the
good stuff from on it from alpha brain
to minerals to vitamins to b12 so you
don't get no [ __ ] jet lag and i'm on
those go to on it.com man listen on it's
there for anything that you're lacking
whether it's
your immune system with shroom tech you
want more oxygen when you work out with
shroom tech sport something is wrong
with your bones they got the buffalo
josh take the buffalo meat yeah okay uh
the the buffalo protein strip i mean on
it has so much to offer all right you
don't have money it's tax season you
don't want to buy nothing you're broke i
get it just go to honor.com go and see
what they have available to you they
have an on it program that you can order
stuff and it gets right to your door on
the first of every month you save 10 a
month plus the 10 percent of you use my
[ __ ] coupon on joeydiaz.net what's
the code church church c-h-u-r-c-h
that's the one found all right so right
there you have it let me talk to you
about something else that's really
important and what i'm gonna talk to you
about
is hulu plus
if i sat here and told you i sit home
every night and watch hulu plus i'm
lying to you but you know who does watch
hulu plus my [ __ ] wife okay and every
time i come home she tells me about you
know hulu plus has kids shows on that
yeah they have so much [ __ ] on there i
didn't know i i knew my family was on
there and the daily show and all that
[ __ ] but they got nashville they got
[ __ ] lost they got doctor who you
know you could watch this on your
smartphone you she watches on roku i
guess that's what she does now i don't
know [ __ ] real cool xbox playstation
pretty much any streaming [ __ ] device
all right it's 7.99 a month if you go to
the web page they're going to give you
[ __ ] one week for free because you're
hanging out with the church and all of
us [ __ ] and you know you lead a
jew
bam
you get two weeks for free and 799 a
month that's 96 dollars a year to
[ __ ] watch anything you wanted and
you can [ __ ] binge watch tv brooklyn
nine-nine is on there there's so many
[ __ ] things they have so many
different goddamn genres from from from
new girl to once upon a time the family
guy i mean i go on for [ __ ] ever they
got kids shows they got reality shark
tank mob wise action adventure marvel's
agents of shield they even got sports
wwe monday i mean cut the [ __ ]
[ __ ] thank you for reminding me
shark tank was on twice last week oh i'm
gonna go home and right after that's
right don't [ __ ] around go to
huluplus.com go to joydears.net go to
the hulu plus and press joey joey get
two weeks for free on the [ __ ] arm
binge everything nashville singing songs
[ __ ] shark tank reality then it's
7.99 a month after that 96 dollars a
year i ain't [ __ ] around with you
people
you know i don't have time to people i
give you the best deal busy man how many
times have you talked to ahri who's
jewish that i always know where they get
the best lunch specials that's what i do
i'm trying to get you the best [ __ ]
deals again you're a man you're a woman
you gotta go to [ __ ] some pharmacy
every month or some outlet place and
stand on line and get razors your razors
get rusty have you seen the [ __ ]
price of raises lately they're expensive
stop it stop it i got the answer right
here at the church of what's happening
now the answer is dollar shave club
[ __ ] the best out there they
got a program for you one dollars a
month six dollars a month or nine
dollars a month what do you get in each
package i don't know go to
dollarshaveclub.com and take a look but
let me tell you just a little bit you
get razors you get one stationary raise
and then they send you a box of blades
every month some blades have two [ __ ]
things with the aloe strip that's the
nine dollar package but let me tell you
something
take it from me take the six dollar
package get the six dollar package it's
72 dollars a [ __ ] year everything
gets sent to your house oh you want to
order the one wipe charlie's and keep
your [ __ ] clean you could do that too
you want to order the cocoa shave butter
for your face to smooth out the humps
and the bumps you could do that too i'm
not asking you to do that all i'm asking
you to do is to take care of yourself
for six dollars a [ __ ] month you get
the razors sent to your goddamn house
you don't gotta go no way you're gonna
sit in traffic dead air bam that's one
less [ __ ] thing in your month go to
joeydears.net go to dollar shave club
what's the code brother church church
c-h-u-r-c-h how easy is that get your
[ __ ] raises today
stop [ __ ] around with yourself also
to my main people at
escapepodtank.com making it happen this
is the third month they're working with
us and i'm working with them and i love
it because everybody who emails me back
says they call jeremy he gives them the
information he sends him brochures he
does whatever he has to do to break it
down for you that's one thing customer
service is [ __ ] key in my world
number two i'm gonna save you two to
three grand on each [ __ ] tub whether
it's a commercial tub or a residential
tub whatever however wherever the [ __ ]
you want to float wherever you want
those nuts to [ __ ] float we'll make
it happen for you go to
escapepodtank.com
call him up call jeremy tell him i sent
you say jeremy [ __ ] answer the phone
cocksuck i got questions for you he'll
answer the [ __ ] phone for you if you
mention me he's going to give you an
additional 250 off so if it's a
commercial tub a residential tub you got
it mailed out to you they'll give you
directions somebody have a contract in
the area they'll come and put the box
together for you but you get an extra
250 off to buy a bag of dope that's what
escape pod tank does
escape podtank.com does for you
[ __ ] all right stop wasting your
money going afloat somewhere just do it
your house go to the bank get along put
a tank in your house you could fart now
you can whack off on that the [ __ ] stays
on the sides who gives a [ __ ] it's yours
right or wrong it's so easy i could put
it together that's right [ __ ] yeah look
at the shape of you what am i gonna do
with you eat another adam no you're not
even [ __ ] hiding yes i am
look at the [ __ ] shape i have a very
serious question what's the question you
want to ask me why don't hotels put
plungers in in the rooms because they're
like that you call downstairs they come
up you charge them five dollars but it's
beautiful because they always want to
plunge your own [ __ ] that's disgusting
they always send some [ __ ] dude look
on his face he's like give me the point
oh no i do it you ain't going in there
i don't want you to see what's in my
[ __ ] [ __ ] you ain't going in there we
went to it's a place called tacos el
gordo apparently it's pretty big in san
diego and stuff and it was some of the
night best tacos we've had we went
through the first night because we our
flight was at nine o'clock
around four in the morning i woke up and
i took a huge [ __ ] to [ __ ] that
background i [ __ ] up the toilet was
tapping off yeah and i i flushed i'm
like oh [ __ ] this isn't going down and i
flush again and i think there's a sensor
in these fancy things so it doesn't
overflow thank god but i i was nervous i
was going to overflow it was right there
to the tip right there so i took the
trash can and i filled it up
just kind of nervous
the thing i could get it to go down
thinking there was a plunger no plunger
i walked down to the front desk hey can
i have a plunger do we have to send an
engineer up i'm like i just want a plum
you must have a buck i thought they had
a bucket of them behind the front desk
no and i'm like i don't want a big guy
coming in at four in the morning making
apollo up so i waited outside in the
hallway luckily he let me do it so i
plunged it no you're supposed to give
him five ten bucks for what to bring the
plunge up and not no they should just
give me a [ __ ] plunger
what are you [ __ ] knowing about
scratching yeah he's another edible
you're supposed to give him a ten spot
to not go in your room i did he didn't
go to my room i didn't i did myself no
did you give me the plunger back yeah
let me ask you he carried it in the bag
yeah no like we think he's gonna walk
around with [ __ ] falling from it you
[ __ ] but i i poured the the trash can
back into the toilet and i flushed it
again and i put the trash can in the bag
too i was like we don't need this in a
room disgustingly and then you don't
give the poor guy
[ __ ] business
what's the matter
nothing doesn't matter who [ __ ] why
don't you have a plunger in a hotel room
because what do you want to have 200
[ __ ] plunges yeah the game they don't
want the [ __ ] to get out of control what
if there's something that that's not
what if your [ __ ] had metal in it
what what what if you ate like a bicycle
okay and you shoot a bicycle in the
[ __ ] thing and it's about to clog up
the toilet that's why they send the guy
he's no engineer
but they send them up there to flush it
to make sure your bathroom's okay you're
supposed to give them a 10 now don't get
me wrong
i would never want somebody to smell the
core of my [ __ ] because once you flush
the toilet and that [ __ ] breaks in half
that's a completely different odor than
you got for originally when it comes out
you get those gastric juices and [ __ ]
yeah when it breaks in half yeah yeah
when it breaks in half leave me alone it
breaks eat one more out of them when it
breaks in half yeah you're sitting there
going it's disgusting i don't want
nobody in there either so i give them a
10 spot to keep them in the hallway yeah
every time i order coffee like when i
get coffee packing you know they only
put two packages in your room that's why
now i gotta travel with [ __ ]
sweetener because i gotta be i've become
a [ __ ] shoplifter i'll sweeten the
shoplifter every time i go to eat when
i'm on the road i look around i gotta
steal the [ __ ] blue packages oh cause
you don't
housekeeping yeah they only put one blue
package in your room with two [ __ ]
pink packages for every cup of coffee i
need like three or four of those
[ __ ] so every time i drink
coffee like i like to drink coffee in
the morning when i wake up
one [ __ ] cup when i wake up in the
morning yeah right just one cup i don't
know how people drink coffee all day and
that night before i do comedy or
sometimes before i go to bed at night
i'll get a cup of coffee and smoke a
joint you know smoke like a vapor and
i love that and write two or three jokes
i love all that [ __ ]
so that's what i use coffee for so i
would come in at night they give you two
pack they give you one pack of decaf
and one pack of regular [ __ ] coffee
i'm gonna be there for four days
when i go to the front desk you think
they got coffee behind the front desk
you think so no
oh
they make an engineer come up to your
[ __ ] room hey should i give him five
dollars for what for to bring the coffee
up oh wouldn't you i'm a nice tipper but
i i draw the line you gotta tip him you
gotta tip
the church you got to give him a [ __ ]
fin a tense butler oh god yeah you're
out there people see you they know
you're international
oh no no i didn't think of those [ __ ]
poor people on the strip [ __ ]
costumes taking pictures
i felt so bad for this one guy who
dressed him and his buddy were burt and
ernie in the [ __ ] worst looking
costumes i've ever seen they must have
sorted themselves but he's like picture
buddy so him and his friend has to come
from the south
to make it big in vegas they were in
homemade partnering costumes
in the [ __ ] 90 degree weather i'm
like oh
thank you you think you got problems
yeah are you gonna go back with me in
vegas july 18th
when is your birthday july 20th and what
are you going to do is paulina i'm
thinking i don't know it's [ __ ] april
what's what's the name of the girl you
want to see lana del rey del reagan [ __ ]
sucker no
i want to go see them all
july 13th is our one year anniversary
and what are you going to do i don't
know what are you planning on i don't
know [ __ ] she has she's
reagan no she's working during the week
this summer so i don't know we'll do
something on the weekend
so you're not gonna go to the south
point with me on the 18th meeting i just
said it would me rick ramos and you okay
you loose
bam maybe that's tonight we're gonna
check the fight in your [ __ ] mouth on
stage at the
at the dirty show you know find the
chick in vegas
to fight your mouth for ten bucks no
huggers no
i'm gonna get a heavy duty black chick
no it was weird what was weird you tell
me at the taco place we saw like two
hookers in their pimp they're having an
end of shift meaning
it was [ __ ] weird and it's also weird
what were they saying that you people no
no i didn't see what i didn't get her
numbers or you put on the podcast no
[ __ ] but i would love to like she gave
him all the money and he like
she paid for the tacos and gave him he
he gave him each a couple of bills
but then he took it i was like what must
that feel like at the end of the night
what was he dressed like he had a
[ __ ] funny shirt onto like ain't
nobody as fly as me or something with
the word fly in it and it was just it
was hysterical and the the hookers in
vegas are hysterical too like they'll
just
position themselves like on the walkways
and like the little they'll be in this
tight
dresses and then also i learned from
somebody if you see a girl like that
alone in a bar that's a hooker too
because why are they alone at the bar
so uh every time we would walk by one i
just pointed out to paul look there's
another hooker
it's uh i don't know it's crazy it's
your hobby now
you're a bad [ __ ] crazy to see
that two years ago you didn't know
nothing now you know hookers [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] ordering plunges to your
room you're [ __ ] blood i don't even
have plungers that's a stupid i'm paying
hundreds of dollars a night to stay
there have a [ __ ] ten dollar plunger
in the room they don't because that's
the scam the engineering the ten spot
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] tense everybody's
gonna make money they union you ever
think that their [ __ ] union you know
what they don't have uber and lyft in
vegas
they don't have those those things in
vegas
it must be the cab unions or something
they must be [ __ ] huge there did you
try the uber
i went out because when we were at the
airport i was just gonna see how much it
was gonna be
um because they have those those shared
ride vans in vegas where you can go up
and down the strip but those take 18
hours to get to your room so we're just
gonna take a cab so i put uber on and
there's no the big thing pops up no uber
or left in vegas how far was how long
was the the taxi line in vegas this time
ooh
at the airport
it wasn't that long but we actually i
i've never taken this when you got there
yeah how bad was it it was only one line
it didn't but i we had to walk through
all those all that [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
nightmare like what the [ __ ] is this let
me just walk to the front and get me a
cab no i want to talk about something
that we don't talk a lot about here
and i know you suffer from it what's the
matter brother i am pretty [ __ ] high
that's right who takes care you like me
huh who takes care of you like your
friends from grand rapids
huh no one this you need one more no
thank you but this is crazy this is
tremendous let's eat one more thing what
the [ __ ] it's monday it's monday
april 14th who's better than you huh
you don't wanna eat one more thing i'm
gonna go for breakfast at lulu's okay
you wanna go get a nice steak we'll get
you a nice steak
i want i want a breakfast sandwich
although it sounds good what kind of
breakfast sandwich bacon egg and cheese
look what kind of cheese tell me each
other so i can hate i don't know what
are they what do they put on the ones i
don't choose it whatever they put on the
like
what are we talking about mimi is a
loser okay he said lulu's probably
i don't know you you said it
around the corner okay mimi's is good
that's a [ __ ] fries but i wouldn't go
if i go there i'm only allowed to eat
one egg wheat toast and [ __ ] fruit
that's what my diet costs for one
scrambled egg wheat toast that's the
biggest thing about the edibles is the
munchies after i got no munchies don't
get munchies no you gotta focus oh my
god i got a cantaloupe at the house i
got strawberries i'm thinking about it
already
i'm gonna eat a whole cantaloupe
don't even don't even take the right i'm
gonna kill that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing oh my god
and then we'll just bite it
up already because it's a babies the
baby eats it too you're gonna have your
babies it's mine it's my cantaloupe but
she cuts up small for the baby too it's
my [ __ ] candle
it's my strawberries there's bananas
there for a baby and tangerines there's
a bunch of fruit
the [ __ ] uh cantaloupe is mine kinda
my wife eats the bananas there's there's
raspberries and uh yeah there's
raspberries with the yogurt yeah and
granola that's for her but the
cantaloupe and the strawberries uncle
joey's that's just the way the [ __ ]
thing goes you see mercy putting your
hand in the ball just looking you're
like what the [ __ ] dog she taught
everything she takes the yoga and throws
in her face
but uh i tell you what's what's
sorry i forgot yeah no i'll tell you
what's a big
problem i didn't know that a lot of
people [ __ ] suffer from insomnia you
have insomnia oh yeah last night i
called you you were better than nine
o'clock oh i was just tired
um
but yeah and so it used to be a lot
worse
it's terrible
a lot of people have that oh yeah well i
think it's a lot of people my age have
it but you know what
the problem there is insomnia but part
of the problem for me too is the tv the
phone the laptop
that that stuff doesn't help what do you
do i mean what kind of insomnia do you
have
it's been better recently when i'm
working a lot
and i get tired during the day it's not
as bad
it would be like
like during the the sad thing is during
college
it's really not that hard to get your
work done so you'll you'll have a lot of
time watching tv
i i've been up until five six in the
morning a lot like for weeks in a row
it's just you can't fall asleep it's
it's terrible when it happens because
you just can't fall asleep it's amazing
my insomnia started well
my insomnia that's what you called it
was family [ __ ] inherited okay oh
yeah
because of the bar business my mother
would come home at three and wake me up
so as i got older i didn't notice it
then but i noticed it when i was 20.
that i would go to bed at 10 o'clock at
night and at [ __ ] 2 30 i'd be up
yeah and uh that's not insomnia
well did you go to bed or did you fall
because i'd fall asleep and then wake up
after four hours no that's i mean when i
think insomnia insomnia is just you
can't fall for sleep okay but i still
wake up and now i can't fall oh okay i
got it so finally in 84 i put together
maybe
because i never thought this is how dumb
i was
in 84 one night i woke up and i'm like
oh
maybe if i smoke pot
i'll fall back to sleep because if i
really think about my uh medical might
really think about my marijuana use i
enjoyed marijuana early on
because it put me to sleep yeah it does
not because of the high or whatever
because i knew that at the end of the
night i would sleep a lot easier but for
a year i woke up at 2 30
and at five i'd fall back to sleep and
what a shame i got to be up at six oh
yeah and that's when i figured out that
if i got high
i would fall back to sleep and that's
what i did i would have a joint i would
just take two hits off
and listen to music for 15 minutes i'd
fall asleep i put the
stereo right next to me with earphones
really just [ __ ] it was amazing
and then as i got older
it came in shifts you know but with me i
have insomnia when i go on the road
oh yeah you do after a comedy show i go
back and i really don't want to go to
bed especially if i don't have to get up
in the morning
you know uh so i didn't understand it
like and
people always hit me up with emails you
know
you know you never talk about insomnia i
don't talk about insomnia because
i don't have insomnia and the fact that
i do have it but i tackled it early on
with reefer yeah and then the other on
the other alternative half insomnia is
exercise
is making yourself tired that that's the
only other thing when i have insomnia if
you go to the gym you're [ __ ] tired
even if you just ride the bike for 30
minutes it will help you sleep a lot
better it really does but a lot of
people always hit me up and inside me i
got to be honest that's the reason why
i smoke pot and yeah they'll tell you
that there's different office
uh a sleepy time tea it has that
whatever in it and and tryptophan what's
in the turkeys that works but you that
[ __ ] don't work forever then you have to
go on sleeping pills which i gotta tell
you they're the worst things [ __ ]
going i don't give a [ __ ] but they give
you a milligram and a half or 10
milligrams of those volumes man you know
i tell you how the [ __ ] it is those
things are horrifically bad because they
stock up
they stack up in your system
valium stacks up in your system so after
a while you're a walking [ __ ] zombie
just waiting to fall asleep you know
so that that's all but you have it
yeah i mean i never had it that bad i
had a pretty bad uh i tried not to do
sleeping pills um for a while you have
to sometimes but they always
prescriptions um but at first they knock
you out
but then slowly like it doesn't work so
you have to take more
so i never let it get that far but
[ __ ] weed
and everyone knows i'm not much of
working out but you keep them busy
that really does because
it's if if you're not getting tired
during the day if you're just at home in
bed watching tv
that's a lot what are you gonna be tired
from no i [ __ ] i get it [ __ ]
it's terrible the worst thing is is when
you have to be up at six you're maybe
you have to work at ten you have to
leave at nine is falling asleep at seven
thirty that i'll tell you what kills me
my game is this yeah i went home last
night i got off the plane at 11 o'clock
i got home by 12. i hung out with the
family for a while the baby took a nap i
took a nap yeah i slept like two hours
the night before i slept three hours i
probably slept an hour and a half on the
plane i'm good for the day let me tell
you what happened to me last night
so at nine o'clock last night my wife
comes in
and she goes i'm going to bed i was just
headed out to get a cup of coffee here i
had a cup of coffee at nine and even
though i really wasn't tired i can't lie
to you people tell you i was tired at
nine o'clock
i had the coffee and i wrote a little
while i did a bunch of [ __ ] that i had
to do i had to get my week ready uh i
looked at my gaming license for [ __ ]
uh
santa fe they sent me a license because
i'm doing that casino so do an indian
casino you have to have a special
license really yes i was looking at that
i was reading up some stuff on there
and uh
i went to bed about eleven i looked at
the clock it was five to eleven guys
you know what time i woke up today one
time
301 like
opened my eyes sat in bed for five or
six minutes
with the decline it was 301.
i said i'm gonna stay in bed till 4 45.
i stayed in bed like 20 minutes
and i got up that's it just like that
guess what what let's pretend you called
me last night you go i need your help at
seven in the morning
will you be here i'll tell you yeah
when i have to get up
i can't get up really that's when i have
to get up in the morning i can't fall
asleep
um you follow me like when i have to get
up for those 4 a.m flights yeah catch me
at 8 o'clock i'm johnny [ __ ] energy
oh my body tricks me they play with me
and i would stay up
in the old days i would stay up now i
force myself to [ __ ] fall asleep
because i have to we have to [ __ ]
so you never could [ __ ] you never
know what the [ __ ] going on we were
supposed to have a guest call in today
we were supposed to have my main man
hector lombard calling ufc fighter
welterweight
but i was kind of scared anyway because
i don't know how good his english was
and lee was telling me just talk to him
in spanish
and i hate that [ __ ] when people do it
so i'm happy in a way that he didn't
call it i love hector but just in
talking to him he didn't really want to
talk about cuba
you know which is uh
what the main conversation would be how
he feels uh
you know what made him go to australia
instead of new york city things like
that what made him go to
you know what what uh i mean his cuban
would made him leave and all that stuff
but he didn't want to cover that stuff
so
everything happens for a reason but i
want to tell you guys i got nothing this
week the next week in the next couple
weeks i'll be on the road with rogue in
baltimore orlando santa barbara so i
really have nothing on my own next time
you'll see me and lee will be wednesday
morning at 6 a.m also april 30th we're
at the ice house for a live
[ __ ] podcast so make sure to
get your tickets now also pre-sale for
t-shirts patches
and the uh cups ends tomorrow we're
pretty much out of patches we're pretty
much out of [ __ ] coffee mugs
how's that for you people so i
appreciate the support
on everything you know listen i'm not
doing this to rape you [ __ ] guys or
make become a millionaire i'm doing this
because you guys asked me for it i
listened to what you guys told me the
geese came the g patches came from when
i go out to jiu jitsu places they always
tell me make a church [ __ ] thing you
guys want a t-shirt i put balls and a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on it for you and a cross
who does that
balls a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] cross that's
a t-shirt and i got the coffee mugs
because we are the church you drink
coffee in the morning or [ __ ] bat
juice or stomink your [ __ ] liquid or
whatever the [ __ ] is lee look at the
shape of you
on a monday morning i'm into the post
office dude better not [ __ ] fall
asleep today because i'll be [ __ ] you
up two times i was in the post office
and you know what was good about coming
home yesterday
but i never talk about anymore my cats
oh [ __ ]
i have rekindled the love with all my
babies again it's very weird
when the baby was born at first i think
sometimes when a child something new
comes in the house it wasn't that i
neglected them
i just uh because i give them all the
same love man i love them all the same i
really do
i have my favorites but i love them all
the same but uh the last
three or four months i've been tight
with them again really tight with them
and you can see the difference they're
having a good time you know let's scare
the [ __ ] baby really yeah they're
scared of them i see especially demi
demi just runs the [ __ ] away from her
but it's amazing how uh
how i'm in love with like this morning i
i was a little late here this morning
because i was with them
i could see that they were really
enjoying themselves i had fidel up in
the air i had the alley up in the air i
had super bad in my arms
and i could just see the difference you
know on monday morning before i leave
the house look to pick them all up and
tell them i love them and kiss them and
it really is a joy someday we're going
to get you a nice dog you're going to be
very happy and i can tell you're really
gonna enjoy you know take a look at your
little uh
your places around your town if you're
lonely or you're feeling depressed or
you're feeling maybe that you can't make
it another day whatever the [ __ ] your
problem is
you know maybe you just [ __ ] want a
dog or a cat go to one of these shelters
that they're gonna kill them and bring
something home yeah at this point in the
game who gives a [ __ ] i tell you they
give me all the joy in the world and
when i'm home i'm happy to see my wife
and i'm happy to see my daughter but i'm
not home until i give those [ __ ] cats
a hug so
do what you do spread the love or tell
them to suck your dick it's the same
thing it's a thin line between love and
[ __ ] hate jackson
and that's it for today if you're jewish
i love you if you [ __ ] muslim i love
you i don't give a [ __ ] today it's
monday april 14th sling dick like i told
you when you walk in the room you got
the biggest dick in that room even if
you [ __ ] don't all right have a great
day stay black let's do this league put
this [ __ ] together baby let me
go to